This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养坚韧的意志、强健的体魄以及建立心理韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些磨难，当你走出困境时，你会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何您收听播客的地方收听《2%》。名字就是“2”这个数字。在《回看当年》（Look Back at It）播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我和黑人来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。就像马马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代那样。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那确实是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您收听播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·盖姆斯为您带来的《艰难求索》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套坚硬的盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您收听播客的任何地方收听《艰难求索》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《情陷迷局》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何您收听播客的地方收听《情陷迷局》播客。欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
Hello, everybody. welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today on the agenda, we have a highly requested episode from all you listeners out there. I ran a poll on my Instagram the other day at That Psychology Podcast. Shameless Plug, if you want to give us a follow. And I essentially asked, what do you want to hear? Overwhelmingly, you always, you always, wanted to hear about the psychology of Lucky Girl Syndrome and guess what we are going to do it. We are going to dive into all of the nitty, gritty science and psychology of this trend.
大家好，欢迎回到本节目，欢迎回到本播客，无论你是新听众还是老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里收听新的一集。今天的节目日程上，我们有一集应广大听众强烈要求的节目。几天前我在我的Instagram上发起了一项投票，账号是That Psychology Podcast。顺便厚着脸皮打个广告，如果你想关注我们的话。我基本上问的是，大家想听什么？压倒性多数的听众一直以来都非常想听关于“幸运女孩综合征”的心理学，你猜怎么着，我们今天就要满足大家。我们将深入探讨这一趋势的所有核心、细节科学和心理学。
And spoiler alert, there are a lot of theories to talk about today. So many more than I anticipated. I think Lucky Girl Syndrome has been doing the rounds across TikTok and Instagram in the past few months. I am sure we have all seen viral videos of people recounting all of the good things that have happened to them, the job offers, the unexpected $50 note on the ground, free coffees, new love interests that have started to crop up once they've adopted this mindset that they are a lucky person. But how much proof is there that positive affirmations like the universe is working in my favour and positive thinking actually. creates tangible changes in our lives. Well, that is where the psychology comes in. I think what sometimes bothers me about this trend is all the people putting it down to luck or manifestation. We are here to bust that myth today by providing some pretty interesting explanations behind the
剧透一下，今天我们要讨论的理论非常多。比我预期的要多得多。我认为“幸运女孩综合征”在过去几个月里一直在TikTok和Instagram上疯狂流传。我敢肯定我们都见过这样的病毒式传播视频：人们讲述发生在他们身上的所有好事，比如工作机会、地上意外出现的50美元钞票、免费的咖啡、当他们采纳了自己是个幸运儿这种心态后开始出现的新恋情。但是，诸如“宇宙正在对我有力”和积极思维等积极肯定是否真的能在我们的生活中产生切实的变化，这其中有多少证据支持呢？好吧，这就是心理学切入的地方。我认为这个趋势有时让我烦恼的是，所有人把它归结为运气或显化。我们今天就是要打破这个迷思，提供一些非常有趣的解释，来剖析
workings of Lucky Girl Syndrome and all that comes with it. We are going to examine theories like self-fulfilling prophecies, confirmation bias, the external versus internal locus of control, the pygmalion theory, and even dive into some of our brain anatomy to explain why this idea of positive and lucky manifestation may actually have some evidence behind it. So come along for the journey, we're going to reveal a lot of the truth and of course the psychology behind this trend and what it actually means for our lives. I will acknowledge there is also a dark side to Lucky Girl Syndrome. I don't think we can discuss this phrase or this concept without also talking about privilege.
“幸运女孩综合征”运作背后的原理以及随之而来的一切。我们将审视诸如自证预言、确认偏误、外在与内在控制点、皮格马利翁效应等理论，甚至深入探讨我们的大脑解剖结构，以解释为什么这种积极和幸运显化的理念实际上可能是有一些科学依据的。所以，请跟随我们一起踏上这段旅程，我们将揭示许多真相，当然还有这一趋势背后的心理学，以及它对我们的生活究竟意味着什么。我必须承认，“幸运女孩综合征”也有其阴暗的一面。我认为我们在讨论这个词或这个概念时，不可能不同时谈论特权。
And that may be controversial, but I do think that at a brief glance of the most popular videos associated with this trend, we will primarily see people who are very attractive, very wealthy, well-off and healthy. And some of the controversy of this trend is that manifestation sometimes ignores things like wealth and privilege in favor of a simple explanation. So I think we should definitely proceed with caution. We will talk about that later. This is probably one of my favorite episodes that I have ever done.
这可能会引发争议，但我确实认为，粗略浏览一下与这一趋势相关的最受欢迎的视频，我们会主要看到那些非常具有吸引力、非常富有、生活优渥且健康的人。这种趋势的一些争议在于，显化有时会为了一个简单的解释而忽视财富和特权等因素。所以我认为我们绝对应该谨慎行事。我们稍后会讨论这一点。这可能是我做过的最喜欢的节目之一。
I know I am setting the expectations high from the outset. but wow when I first started researching this I had no idea what I would find and it has blown my mind so I am really excited to be able to share if you have been confused or skeptical of this lucky girl trend you're in the right place we have a lot to discuss today so let's jump right into it for those of you who are thinking what in the world is lucky girl syndrome and have no idea what I'm talking about, you're just along for the ride. Let me give you a brief synopsis and overview. This idea has emerged largely on TikTok and trending videos in which people essentially explain how by convincing themselves and believing that they are lucky, good
我知道我从一开始就把大家的期望值抬得很高，但是天哪，当我刚开始研究这个课题时，我根本不知道自己会发现什么，它彻底震撼了我的脑海，所以我真的很高兴能与大家分享。如果你一直对这个幸运女孩的潮流感到困惑或怀疑，那么你来对地方了。我们今天有很多内容要讨论，所以让我们直接切入正题。对于那些脑海中想着“这世上到底什么是幸运女孩综合征”却完全不知道我在说什么，只是顺便了解的人，我来做一个简短的梗概和概述。这个概念主要出现在TikTok和热门视频中，人们在视频中基本上解释了他们如何通过说服自己并相信自己是幸运的，好运就会
things inevitably happen to them. It's often accompanied by certain affirmations and positive thinking statements. One of the most popular audios that goes along with these videos is about how your life is supposed to go well and things are meant to work out for you. These creators essentially say that their secret to a great life is assuming and believing that they will have a great life. And with that, they show how they have received all these amazing benefits. Like I mentioned, new jobs and unexpected money and new outfits and positive news. you will find thousands, maybe millions at this point, of videos exactly like this, all across TikTok and platforms like Instagram.
事情不可避免地会发生在他们身上。这通常伴随着某些肯定语和积极的思维陈述。伴随这些视频最流行的音频之一，是关于你的人生应该一帆风顺、事情注定会朝着对你有利的方向发展。这些创作者本质上是在说，他们美好生活的秘诀就是假设并相信自己会拥有美好的生活。随之，他们展示了自己是如何获得所有这些惊人的好处的。正如我所提到的，新工作、意外之财、新服装以及积极的消息。你会发现成千上万，甚至此时此刻数以百万计的完全相同的视频，遍布整个TikTok以及Instagram等平台。
Although this idea of Lucky Girl Syndrome really began to trend last year, it's not entirely a new concept. In fact, it's essentially just manifestation or the idea of manifestation that has been wrapped up in fancy packaging and given a new name for this generation. Let's go back a little bit. The origins of manifestation, which is essentially what Lucky Girl syndrome is, it can be traced back to various philosophical and spiritual traditions, such as Hinduism, Buddhism, Greek philosophy, even Christianity, among others. But the idea that we now speak of and that we normally think of when we think of manifestation, it was popularized
尽管“幸运女孩综合征”这个概念在去年真正开始流行，但它并不是一个完全崭新的概念。事实上，它本质上只是显化，或者说是被包装在精美外表下、并为这一代人赋予了新名字的显化理念。让我们稍微回溯一下。显化的起源——这本质上也就是幸运女孩综合征的内核——可以追溯到各种哲学和精神传统，例如印度教、佛教、希腊哲学、甚至基督教等等。但我们现在所谈论的、以及当我们想到显化时通常会想到的那个理念，它是在
in quite a few pop psychology books and publications that were released in the early 2000s, and then the idea was scooped up by people like Oprah and other inspirational thought leaders until it kind of trickled down to everyday people like you and I. Vox wrote a really fascinating article on this topic. I will leave it in the description, and it essentially concludes that Lucky Girl Syndrome is just the latest revokely. of historical ideas like the law of attraction or assumption, which essentially proposed that our thoughts and our beliefs can alter our reality. For example, believing that I will be rich will make you rich and you attract what you desire and what you put out into the universe. If you think this sounds
2000年代初期出版的相当多的流行心理学书籍和出版物中得到普及的，随后这个概念被奥普拉和其他励志思想领袖等人物采纳，直到它逐渐渗透到像你我这样的普通人中。Vox就这个话题写了一篇非常精彩的文章。我将把它留在简介里，它本质上得出的结论是：“幸运女孩综合征”不过是对历史观念（如吸引力法则或假设法则）的最新一次死灰复燃，这些法则本质上提出，我们的思想和信念可以改变我们的现实。例如，相信我会变富有就会让你变富有，你吸引的是你渴望的东西以及你向宇宙散发的东西。如果你觉得这听起来
very simplified and undervalues the power of individual action, hard work and agency, you are not the only one. Manifestation, the law of assumption, attraction, and with that, trends like Lucky Girl Syndrome have been repeatedly criticized by many psychologists as being essentially a pseudo-scientific self-help trend with no basis in actual science or traditional academic research to back it up.
非常简单化，并且低估了个人行动、努力工作和主体性的力量，那么你并不是唯一一个这么想的人。显化、假设法则、吸引力法则，以及随之而来的像“幸运女孩综合征”这样的潮流，一直遭到许多心理学家的反复批评，认为它们本质上是一种伪科学的自助潮流，没有任何实际科学或传统学术研究的基础来支持它们。
Of course, you can't make magical things automatically happen with your mind. as far as we know, that's not physically possible at this stage. But when we dive deeper into the science behind the impact of positive affirmations on our brain, we might reach a different conclusion. And it doesn't have anything to do with abstract concepts like mind control or fate or the power of the universe, but with how our minds can be altered by our beliefs to approach life in a way that does impact our decision making, our outlook, our success, and therefore, the outcomes of our lives. At the end of the day, the power of Lucky Girl Syndrome is that it retrains our brain into adopting
当然，你不可能仅凭大脑就自动让神奇的事情发生。据我们所知，在这个阶段这在物理上是不可能的。但当我们深入探讨积极肯定语对我们大脑影响背后的科学时，我们可能会得出不同的结论。这与诸如精神控制、命运或宇宙力量等抽象概念没有任何关系，而是关于我们的心灵如何被我们的信念所改变，从而以一种确实会影响我们的决策、我们的视野、我们的成功、并进而影响我们生活结果的方式来对待生活。归根结底，“幸运女孩综合征”的力量在于它重新训练了我们的大脑，使其接受
a more positive mindset. Therefore, by believing you're a lucky person, by repeating it as a lot of these videos instruct you to do, and that you deserve good things, and that you will be successful, you actually have a greater tendency to seek out experiences, situations, opportunities, in which this is confirmed. There has been legitimate studies on this, and it backs up some of those anecdotal experiences we see on social media. One study in particular, it hypothesized that believing you are lucky or some other positive statement about yourself,
一种更积极的心态。因此，通过相信自己是一个幸运的人，通过像许多这类视频所指示的那样不断重复这一点，以及相信你值得拥有美好的事物、你将会成功，你实际上会有更大的倾向去寻找能够证实这一点的经历、情况和机会。这方面已经有过合法的研究，它支持了我们在社交媒体上看到的一些轶事经验。特别是有一项研究，它假设相信自己很幸运或是关于你自己的某种其他积极陈述，
it promotes positive goal-orientated behavior, which in turn produces those positive outcomes. It's not that we manifested these things, but that because of our beliefs, we implicitly and unconsciously work harder, we pursue more opportunities, and these actions are what produces the outcomes associated with Lucky Girl Syndrome. It's not so much spiritual, it's not so much to do with the universe or some intangible force, it really is based in the mind.
它会促进积极的、以目标为导向的行为，进而产生那些积极的结果。并不是我们显化了这些事情，而是因为我们的信念，我们在不知不觉中和潜意识里更加努力，我们追求更多的机会，而正是这些行动产生了与“幸运女孩综合征”相关的结果。它没有那么神秘，它与宇宙或某种无形的力量没有太大关系，它确实立足于心灵。
This can be explained by the psychological concept of self-fulfilling prophecies, otherwise known as the Pygmalian effect. In psychology, a self-fulfilling prophecy revolves around this idea that our expectations impact how we act, which as a result impacts the outcome so that it is the one that we expected. A self-fulfilling prophecy, just to give you more of a definition, it's basically a belief or an expectation that an individual holds about something in the future that manifests purely because the individual believes it, and therefore it impacts their actions. There are some real world and clinical examples that confirm this theory.
这可以用心理学概念“自证预言”（也称为皮格马利翁效应）来解释。在心理学中，自证预言围绕着这样一个理念：我们的期望会影响我们的行事方式，从而反过来影响结果，使其成为我们所预期的那个结果。为了给你更进一步的定义，自证预言基本上是个人对未来的某种信念或期望，它之所以显现，纯粹是因为个人相信它，从而影响了他们的行动。有一些真实世界和临床案例证实了这一理论。
The first one that comes to mind is the placebo effect. When we believe something like a medication will work, that inadvertently alters how our mind perceives our response and our reaction and the impact of the medication. making it so that we either actually display a positive response or our brains mimic positive symptoms in order to confirm our belief that the medication is effective. I know that sounds like a kind of a random example, but what it shows is the power of the mind to actually alter our environment in some ways
我脑海中浮现的第一个例子就是安慰剂效应。当我们相信某种药物（如药物）会起作用时，这会无意中改变我们的大脑对我们自身反应、身体反应以及药物影响的感知。这使得我们要么确实表现出积极的反应，要么我们的大脑会模仿积极的症状，以证实我们对药物有效的信念。我知道这听起来像是一个有点随机的例子，但它展示了心灵的力量，它确实能在某种程度上改变我们的环境
because of how strong it wants to believe in something. That's why when they do clinical trials with new medications, they give one group a placebo and one group a medication that actually works to see whether it's just purely the act of taking the medication and believing that it will work that helps people. In one particularly famous study that my fellow psychology students will definitely know about, they examined the grades of children before and after they wore fake glasses to see whether it would influence how the teachers treated them or how these students performed themselves. And what they found was that their grades actually improved because teachers implicitly associate
因为它对相信某事的强烈渴望。这就是为什么在对新药物进行临床试验时，他们会给一组人安慰剂，给另一组人真正起作用的药物，以观察这仅仅是由于服药并相信它会起作用这一行为本身在帮助人们。在其中一个特别著名的心理学学生绝对会知道的著名研究中，他们检查了儿童在佩戴假眼镜之前和之后的成绩，以观察这是否会影响老师对待他们的方式或这些学生自己的表现。他们发现他们的成绩确实提高了，因为老师们潜意识里把
glasses with intelligence. Therefore, they treated the students better, they showed them more attention, they were more involved in the academic success because they held an implicit belief that glasses equals academic ability. So it shows how our belief system, will unconsciously impact how we choose to act and behave in a way that will confirm our pre-existing beliefs, resulting in our expectation becoming a reality. This also occurs on an individual level as well, as explained by the Pygmalion effect, whereby our self-imposed expectations alter how we behave, and therefore where we end up. If you believe that you attract good people, that you are magnetic and attractive and beautiful,
眼镜与智慧联系在了一起。因此，他们对学生更好，给予他们更多关注，更多地参与到他们的学业成功中，因为他们抱着一种隐性的信念：眼镜等于学业能力。所以这表明，我们的信念系统将如何无意识地影响我们选择以何种方式行动和表现，从而证实我们原有的信念，导致我们的期望成为现实。这在个人层面上也会发生，正如皮格马利翁效应所解释的那样，我们自加的期望改变了我们的行为方式，进而改变了我们的归宿。如果你相信你会吸引优秀的人，你具有磁性、迷人且美丽，
you will behave this way based on your belief system and people pick up on that energy and how you hold yourselves and will react to that attitude. It's part of the reason why we always say that confidence matters more than conventional beauty because people will react to how you hold yourself and treat you accordingly. And it's an example of how the beliefs we hold about ourselves, therefore impact how we act,
你会根据你的信念系统以这种方式行事，而人们会捕捉到那种能量以及你展现自我的方式，并对那种态度做出反应。这就是为什么我们总是说自信比传统美更重要的一部分原因，因为人们会对你展现自我的方式做出反应并做出相应的对待。这是我们对自己的信念如何反过来影响我们行动的一个例子，
which actually creates the positive outcome that we expected in the first place. Of course, this doesn't always happen voluntarily or on a conscious level, hence why we don't always attribute the fruits of our labour to our actions, but rather this idea of manifestation. Essentially, we are stubborn creatures and we don't like to be wrong, so our minds work behind the scenes in order to make our beliefs a reality so that we avoid the pain of being embarrassed or questioning ourselves, and therefore injuring our self-esteem.
这实际上创造了我们最初所期望的积极结果。当然，这并不总是自愿或在意识层面上发生的，因此我们并不总是将劳动的果实归功于我们的行动，而是归功于这种显化的理念。本质上，我们是顽固的生物，我们不喜欢承认自己是错的，所以我们的大脑在幕后工作，以使我们的信念成为现实，从而避免尴尬或自我质疑带来的痛苦，进而伤害我们的自尊。
That is essentially the psychological basis behind Lucky Girl Syndrome and behind positive affirmations. In another vein, though, this idea of confirmation bias can also be used to explain this phenomena, whereby our brains will unconsciously work to affirm your belief by ignoring instances or experiences that don't align with your idea of being lucky, like getting a parking fine or slipping on the street, and it will amplify the events that confirm the idea that you are lucky,
这本质上就是“幸运女孩综合征”和积极肯定语背后的心理学基础。然而，在另一方面，确认偏误的理念也可以用来解释这种现象，即我们的大脑会无意识地工作，通过忽视那些不符合你“幸运”观念的实例或经历（比如吃到停车罚单或在街上滑倒）来确认你的信念，并会放大那些证实你很幸运这一观念的事件，
such as something favorable happening for you, and we end up having an altered view of our reality. Confirmation bias essentially refers to our tendency to process information by looking for or interpreting information that is consistent with our values and what we expect, and ignoring counter-evidence. And all of this offers a deeper insight into the underlying psychology. of Lucky Girl Syndrome and the broader idea of manifestation. Our brain is phenomenal. It is a very,
例如发生在你身上的好事，最终我们对现实的看法发生了扭曲。确认偏误本质上是指我们通过寻找或解释与我们的价值观和期望相一致的信息、同时忽视反面证据来处理信息的倾向。所有这一切都为“幸运女孩综合征”以及更广泛的显化理念提供了对潜在心理学的更深入洞察。我们的大脑非常了不起。它是一个非常、
very powerful tool. And what we tell it will impact our reality, not in some hidden way, but because our brains will alter how we act. Maybe I'm getting repetitive with that, but I really think it's an important link or kind of thought to follow through. But it doesn't mean that positive affirmations and positive self-talk aren't actually highly beneficial. Regardless of some of the flimsy scientific reasoning and the impact of self-fulfilling prophecies and confirmation bias, I do truly believe in the psychological power and impact of affirmations on our life, particularly how we interpret the world. I have talked about affirmations before in my confidence episode and in some of my other episodes. They've worked for,
非常强大的工具。我们对它说的话将影响我们的现实，不是以某种隐蔽的方式，而是因为我们的大脑会改变我们的行动方式。也许我一直在重复这一点，但我真的认为这是一个重要的环节或值得深入思考的思路。但这并不意味着积极的肯定语和积极的自我对话实际上没有高度的益处。撇开一些脆弱的科学推理以及自证预言和确认偏误的影响不谈，我确实坚信肯定语对我们生活的心理力量和影响，尤其是我们如何诠释这个世界。我之前在我的自信单集以及我的一些其他单集中谈论过肯定语。它们对我有用，
me and there are a number of scientific explanations that confirm this. I'm going to dive into them in just a second. Let's discuss some of the evidence for Lucky Girl Syndrome, manifestation, whatever you want to call it. Like I mentioned before, much of the evidence for this trend rests upon the power of affirmation and positive thinking or self-talk. I'm going to use an explanation from the Berkeley Institute to explain this because they said it very well. When we repeat positive affirmations enough, we begin to integrate these statements into our belief system, which in turn creates a more positive mindset. And a more positive mindset is associated with things like greater resilience and optimism, problem solving, and as a result, life satisfaction,
并且有许多科学解释证实了这一点。我马上就会深入探讨它们。让我们讨论一些支持“幸运女孩综合征”、显化、无论你想怎么称呼它的证据。正如我之前提到的，这一潮流的大部分证据都依赖于肯定语和积极思维或自我对话的力量。我将用伯克利研究所的解释来阐述这一点，因为他们说得非常好。当我们足够频繁地重复积极的肯定语时，我们开始将这些陈述整合到我们的信念系统中，这反过来又会创造出更积极的心态。而更积极的心态与诸如更强的韧性和乐观精神、解决问题的能力等事物相关联，结果就是生活满意度、
less stress and better coping skills. That is, the mechanism behind this technique. There are a number of affirmations associated with Lucky Girl's Syndrome that I want to pause and talk about for just a second. Here are a few of my favorites. I really did do my research. I was very interested when I started seeing all these TikToks come up on my feed. I may or may not have written some of them down before I really looked into it. But these were the ones that I actually had in my notes app and I thought they were interesting to share. So some of the affirmations you will see in these trending videos, you may have already seen them, are things like great things are always happening to me. I am so lucky.
更少的压力和更好的应对技巧。这就是这项技术背后的机制。有许多与“幸运女孩综合征”相关的肯定语，我想停下来谈论一会儿。以下是我最喜欢的一些。我确实做了研究。当我开始看到所有这些TikTok出现在我的信息流中时，我很感兴趣。在我真正深入研究之前，我可能已经把其中一些写下来了。但这些是我实际上记在备忘录里的，我认为分享它们很有趣。因此，你在这些热门视频中会看到的一些肯定语，你可能已经见过了，它们是诸如：好事总是发生在我身上。我太幸运了。
Everything is always working out for me. The universe is working in my favour. There's something that these all have in common. They all concern things that have to do with some external source of power or fate. And although they may work, if you truly want to use affirmations and unlock their psychological power, you need to change them to be focused on your strength and your power and your agency and your qualities rather than some external intangible force that's acting beyond your control.
一切总是对我很顺利。宇宙正在对我有力地发挥作用。这些都有一个共同点。它们都涉及与某种外部力量或命运来源有关的事情。尽管它们可能会起作用，如果你真的想使用肯定语并释放它们的心理力量，你需要将它们转变为关注你自己的力量、你的权力、你的能动性和你的品质，而不是某种超出你控制范围的外部无形力量。
So let me give you some examples. Instead of saying things like great things are always happening to me or everything always works out for me, say things like, I am always moving towards something better. I am an intelligent and strong person. I deserve love. I work to attract good things into my life. These affirmations are all about how you see yourself. And at the end of the day, that is the only factor you really have control over. When we routinely use affirmations concerning things beyond our control, it can often lead to a negative or toxic mindset. whereby we blame all of the good things in our lives, all of the bad things,
所以让我给你举几个例子。不要说“好事总是发生在我身上”或“一切对我总是很顺利”这样的话，而是要说：“我总是在朝着更好的方向前进。我是一个聪明而坚强的人。我值得被爱。我努力将美好的事物吸引到我的生活中。”这些肯定语完全关乎你如何看待自己。归根结底，那是你唯一真正能控制的因素。当我们习惯性地使用涉及我们控制之外的事物的肯定语时，它往往会导致消极或有毒的心态。在这种心态下，我们将生活中的所有好事、所有坏事，
on elements beyond our control. And there is a slight problem with that, because it rests on this idea of an internal versus an external locus of control. I'm going to give you a summary, if you've never heard about this before, but essentially, people who believe that external forces like luck and fate or the universe determine their outcomes, they have an external locus of control, whereby there are things beyond their power that are acting beyond their kind of mindset or vision
都归咎于我们控制之外的因素。这里有一个小问题，因为它建立在内部与外部控制点的理念之上。如果你从未听说过这个，我来为你做一个总结：本质上，那些认为运气、命运或宇宙等外部力量决定他们结果的人，他们拥有外部控制点，即有他们力量之外的事情在超越他们的心态或愿景发挥作用，
that are truly responsible for what's happening in their life, hence the term external. In comparison, those who hold themselves responsible for their successes, they have an internal locus of control, internal meaning individual. Having an external locus of control has been repeatedly associated with things like less motivation, more problematic behaviors, even in some studies criminal behavior, not saying that that's always the case.
这些事情真正对他们生活中发生的事情负责，因此被称为“外部”。相比之下，那些认为自己对成功负责的人，他们拥有内部控制点，内部意味着个人。拥有外部控制点一再与较少的动机、更多的问题行为（甚至在某些研究中包括犯罪行为，并不是说情况总是如此）联系在一起。
But people who have an external locus of control, they're more likely to be quite pessimistic and they're more likely to be inactive in the face of adversity. And that makes sense, right? Because if you truly believe that everything is outside of your power and outside of your control, you're going to act accordingly. So when things are happening in your life that you might actually be able to change, your whole mindset is focused on things moving without you needing to do anything. So you become inactive and therefore some of your life outcomes might be declining or become worse. This is why I really recommend that if you are someone who uses affirmations,
但是拥有外部控制点的人更有可能相当悲观，并且在逆境面前更有可能不作为。这讲得通，对吧？如果你真的相信一切都在你的力量和控制范围之外，你就会采取相应的行动。因此，当你的生活中发生你实际上可能能够改变的事情时，你的整个心态都集中在事情不需要你做任何事就能自行发展上。所以你会变得不作为，因此你的一些生活结果可能会下降或变糟。这就是为什么我强烈建议，如果你是一个使用肯定语的人，
that they be about your own abilities. Like I said, the only thing that you can control in your life is your own actions is yourself. So it's important to reinforce that, thereby enabling you to feel more successful when good things happen, but also understand that you can change your reality when bad things happen. I'm very sorry, I've gone on a bit of a tangent there. I realize that now. I've just gone way off course, so let's get back on track.
它们应该关于你自己的能力。就像我说的，你在生活中唯一能控制的就是你自己的行动，就是你自己。所以强化这一点很重要，从而使你在好事发生时感到更有成就感，同时也明白当坏事发生时你可以改变你的现实。非常抱歉，我刚才有点扯远了。我现在意识到了。我刚刚偏离主题太远了，让我们回到正轨。
Why do affirmations work on a neurological level? Well, it has a lot to do with one brain structure in particular. it's called the recticular activating system. And this part of the brain is located just above the midbrain. It's pretty small. It's kind of tiny, actually, but it is responsible for a lot of really important things, like wakefulness, our ability to focus. But most importantly, in this topic, how we perceive the world.
为什么肯定语在神经层面起作用？这与大脑中的一个特定结构有很大关系。它被称为网状激活系统。大脑的这个部分位于中脑上方。它很小。其实有点微小，但它负责许多非常重要的事情，比如清醒度、我们集中注意力的能力。但在这个话题中最重要的是，我们如何感知世界。
Its main function is to choose what information in our environment to process and which stuff that we can disregard as irrelevant and we can filter it out. Consider it like a metal detector for our brain. It only buzzes, for lack of a better word, when we come across something that we deem as important. So it filters things out. It says, you know, that random thing on the sidewalk, we might see it. Our eyes might pick up on it as something in our environment, but we probably can't remember it because our brain, particularly our reticular formation, has chosen to ignore it. That's how it works. And our mindset, our outlook, our set of beliefs and expectations about the world is what the recticular activating system enlists to undertake this filtering process. And surprise,
它的主要功能是选择环境中要处理的信息，以及我们可以作为不相关信息加以忽视并将其过滤掉的内容。把它想象成我们大脑的金属探测器。只有在我们遇到我们认为是重要的事情时，它才会发出蜂鸣声（找不到更好的词了）。所以它会过滤掉一些东西。它会说，你知道的，人行道上的那个随机事物，我们可能会看到它。我们的眼睛可能会将其作为我们环境中的东西捕捉到，但我们可能记不住它，因为我们的大脑，特别是我们的网状结构，选择忽略它。这就是它的运作方式。我们的心态、我们的视野、我们对世界的信念和期望集就是网状激活系统用来开展这一过滤过程的东西。惊喜
surprise, guess what can greatly impact that belief system? You guessed it. Positive self-talk and affirmations. When we believe we are strong and intelligent, when we believe we are lucky, this system, this part of our brains, will confirm that for us. It might not be objectively true that we are lucky or that we are strong, but when we believe it, we feel it, we see it, so that's what really matters. That is basically a very roundabout way of saying that there may be some truth in Lucky Girl syndrome when we break it down to its core components. It's not mystical, it's not some magical thing, it's very much neurological, and
惊喜，猜猜是什么能极大影响那个信念系统？你猜对了。积极的自我对话和肯定语。当我们相信自己坚强而聪明时，当我们相信自己很幸运时，这个系统、我们大脑的这个部分就会为我们证实这一点。我们很幸运或我们很坚强可能在客观上并非真实，但当我们相信它时，我们感受到了，我们看到了，所以这才是真正重要的。这基本上是用一种非常曲折的方式在说，当我们把“幸运女孩综合征”剥离到核心成分时，它可能确实包含一些真相。它不是神秘的，它不是什么神奇的事情，它在很大程度上是神经学的，以及
psychological, whereby it's based in the kind of systems and patterns of behavior and habits that are brain inless to protect us in some ways and to sort out the information in our environment. So it can be very powerful. It can be very impactful on our lives. However, I don't think I would be doing this topic justice if I didn't mention the inherent privilege associated with Lucky Girl Syndrome. I think it is very easy, like I said, to believe that you are lucky and destined for greatness and that everything works out for you when you are already coming from a place of extreme wealth and opportunity and particularly privilege in many Western societies.
心理学的，它建立在大脑为了在某些方面保护我们并对我们环境中的信息进行分类而动员的各种系统、行为模式和习惯之中。所以它可以非常强大。它会对我们的生活产生很大的影响。然而，如果我不提及与“幸运女孩综合征”相关的固有特权，我就没有公正对待这个话题。我认为，正如我所说，当你已经来自一个极端财富、机会、尤其是许多西方社会的特权背景时，很容易相信自己很幸运、注定伟大且一切对你都很顺利。
I can admit that I am one of these people. You know, I grew up in Australia, which is a relatively safe place. I'm well-educated. As are my parents, I have a nice job, and yes, I did work hard to get to this place. But it doesn't mean that there weren't a lot of factors in my favour from day one, from the day I was born. Now that I think about it, I don't think I've seen any videos of people claiming that Lucky Girl Syndrome works for them out of developing countries or places with famine or drought or war. It feels particularly elitist to suggest that just believing good things
我可以承认我是这些人之一。你知道，我在澳大利亚长大，这是一个相对安全的地方。我受过良好教育。我的父母也是如此，我有一份不错的工作，是的，我确实通过努力才走到今天这个位置。但这并不意味着从第一天起、从我出生那天起，就没有很多对我有利的因素。现在想来，我想我还没有见过任何视频，里面来自发展中国家或发生饥荒、干旱或战争的地方的人声称“幸运女孩综合征”对他们管用。暗示只要相信美好的事物
will make your life good. You know, if it was that simple, we wouldn't see so much suffering in the world. It looks like, to me at least, that that this trend is very much reserved for individuals who, the majority of which, already have all the tools that would have enabled their success anyways. It's not luck that has given them a good life. It's not positive self-talk. It's this kind of global, systemic, ingrained system of wealth distribution and inequality. Maybe that's an inconvenient truth.
就会让你的生活变得美好，这显得格外精英主义。你知道，如果事情有那么简单，我们就不会看到世界上有那么多的苦难了。至少在我看来，这种潮流非常留给那些绝大多数已经拥有能够促成其成功的各种工具的个人。赋予他们美好生活的不是运气。不是积极的自我对话。而是这种全球性的、系统性的、根深蒂固的财富分配和不平等系统。也许这是一个令人不快的真相。
it might upset some people, but I do think that it deserves some focus. We can't be blind to some of the reasoning behind this stuff. I think trends like Lucky Girl Syndrome have a habit of becoming these huge internet sensations and attracting a lot of craze whilst minimizing a lot of the crucial truths and kind of pushing sometimes a dangerous narrative that simply believing is going to fix all of your problems when we know when we look at the world that it probably doesn't. Of course, no singular individual or creator or person who supports this trend is to blame. It's not about shaming people and being like you should be embarrassed or you should be ashamed that you believe this.
这可能会惹恼一些人，但我确实认为这值得关注。我们不能对这一切背后的某些逻辑视而不见。我认为“幸运女孩综合征”这类潮流有一个习惯，就是会成为那种轰动互联网的巨大热潮，吸引大量的狂热追捧，同时却淡化了许多至关重要的真相，有时甚至在兜售一种危险的叙事，即只要相信就能解决你所有的问题，而当我们审视这个世界时，我们知道事实并非如此。当然，没有任何一个单一的个人、创作者或支持这一潮流的人应该受到责备。这并不是为了羞辱别人，好像在说你应该对自己的信仰感到尴尬或羞耻一样。
I really don't think that's the case. On an individual level, I think it can be really, really beneficial. Like, I do genuinely believe in the power of a positive mindset. But I do think it's important to believe and recognize both things at once, that it is based in a system of privilege. Not everyone is going to have a lucky girl syndrome experience, but for some individuals, it can be pretty life-changing to shift to a positive mindset for the pursuit of your own goals and your ambitions in life. Also, we haven't mentioned this yet, but whether you are an innately pessimistic or optimistic person also seems to matter when we discuss manifestation. or Lucky Girl Syndrome.
我真的不认为会是这样。在个人层面，我认为这真的可以非常有益。比如，我确实发自内心地相信积极心态的力量。但我确实认为，同时相信并认识到这两点很重要，即它植根于特权体系之中。并不是每个人都能有“幸运女孩综合征”的体验，但对于某些人来说，为了追求人生目标和抱负而转变为积极的心态，可能会带来相当大的人生改变。此外，我们还没提到这一点，但当我们讨论吸引力法则或“幸运女孩综合征”时，你天生是悲观主义者还是乐观主义者似乎也很重要。
And it's very important and relative to the quote-unquote success of these mechanisms and these tools for manifesting a lucky and a happy life. A pretty brief explanation, but essentially there is a difference between people who are optimistic and pessimistic. I feel like most people know that. But an optimistic person, they see good things everywhere. They're really confident and hopeful about what the future holds. They believe that things will work out for them.
而且这对于实现幸运和幸福生活的这些机制和工具的所谓“成功”非常重要，也与之息息相关。这是一个相当简短的解释，但本质上，乐观主义者和悲观主义者之间存在差异。我觉得大多数人都知道这一点。但乐观主义者，他们处处看到美好事物。他们对未来充满信心和希望。他们相信事情会朝着对他们有利的方向发展。
They are very happy and have a great outlook on the potential opportunities that will come their way. The pessimist, on the other hand, they observe mainly the negative aspects of everything around them. They are always prepared for the worst. They always expect the worst. They see the world as kind of a scary, dangerous, ambiguous space. I think it's common sense, but we can see that a positive mindset and a perception of our inherent luckiness is going to be a lot harder for someone who is generally pessimistic. And pessimism is not always something that you can change. Attributes like pessimism and optimism, they obviously fall on a spectrum, but they are a core part of our personality and our temperament that we are born with.
他们非常快乐，对可能迎面而来的机遇抱有极好的期待。相比之下，悲观主义者主要观察周围一切事物的消极方面。他们随时准备面对最坏的情况。他们总是期待最坏的结果。他们把世界看作是一种可怕的、危险的、模棱两可的空间。我认为这是常识，但我们可以看出，对于一个通常悲观的人来说，积极的心态和对自己天生幸运的感知要困难得多。而且悲观主义并不总是你能改变的东西。悲观和乐观之类的特质显然存在于一个光谱上，但它们是我们生来就有的性格和气质的核心部分。
So they can be very hard to shift or to alter. So saying to a friend who is pessimistic that in order to secure their future, all they need to do is manifest good things or have a positive outlook or repeat a certain number of affirmations every day, I don't think it's going to be entirely helpful. If anything, it could potentially be quite patronizing. Of course, there are some things you can do to break out of a pessimistic mindset. I actually think that's an entirely separate episode. That's going to make such a good episode. I should really do that. But I think it just goes to show that distinction between people who are optimistic and pessimistic
所以它们很难转变或改变。因此，对一个悲观的朋友说，为了保障他们的未来，他们所需要做的只是显化美好的事物、保持积极的心态，或者每天重复一定数量的肯定语，我认为这不会完全有帮助。如果非要说有什么作用的话，它可能具有相当大的居高临下的意味。当然，你可以采取一些措施来打破悲观的心态。我实际上认为这是一个完全独立的话题。那会是一个非常棒的话题。我真的应该做那一期。但我觉得这恰恰说明了乐观主义者和悲观主义者之间的这种区别
that the application of being a lucky girl is going to be very nuanced and differ from person to person. It's a nice thing to believe and probably very easy. If you are naturally optimistic, I'm going to call myself out here. That's what I'm like. But it's not as simple as the trending TikTok sounds and viral videos make it same. So what have we learned today? I think Lucky Girl Syndrome is a very attractive idea. It is very attractive to be told that you can sort your life out, you can have an amazing
即“幸运女孩”的应用将是非常微妙的，因人而异的。相信这一点是一件美好的事，而且可能非常容易，如果你天生乐观的话——我要在这里说一下自己，我就是这样的人。但这并不像TikTok上的热门音乐和病毒式视频所呈现的那样简单。那么我们今天学到了什么？我认为“幸运女孩综合征”是一个非常吸引人的概念。有人告诉你，通过做一些非常简单的事情，比如每天对自己重复一系列短语或词汇，你就能理顺你的人生，拥有精彩的生活，这非常有吸引力。
life by doing something really simple like repeating to yourself a series of phrases or words every day. And I do really see the benefit in that. From a psychological perspective, like we mentioned, having a positive mindset is very indicative of later on life satisfaction and success because it will subjectively change how you perceive the world, how you act, and how you see your successes versus your failures. But when we dig deeper into it, we can see that Lucky Girl Syndrome or manifestation, the law of attraction, all of those things. It doesn't really have anything to do with some mystical, higher up source
而我确实看到了其中的益处。从心理学的角度来看，正如我们所提到的，拥有积极的心态非常预示着晚的生活满意度和成功，因为它会主观地改变你如何感知世界、如何行事，以及你如何看待自己的成功与失败。但当我们深入挖掘时，我们可以看出“幸运女孩综合征”或显化法则、吸引力法则，所有这些事情，其实都与某个神秘的、更高阶的无限智慧与力量的来源无关
of infinite wisdom and power. It's not about the universe. It's not about some abstract idea. It's really about our brains and how our brains are taught to process information and how they implicitly impact our actions and our behavior to create positive outcomes and confirm our expectations and our biases. So it is a very complicated interaction, I think, a very interesting interaction. one that I am very glad we talked about today and will say if you are someone who believes in Lucky Girl Syndrome, congratulations, that is amazing. People are allowed to have their own opinions and are allowed to view their lives a certain way.
它与宇宙无关，与某种抽象的概念无关。它真正关乎的是我们的大脑，关乎我们的大脑是如何被教导去处理信息的，以及它们如何潜移默化地影响我们的行动和行为，从而创造积极的结果并证实我们的期望和偏见。因此，我认为这是一个非常复杂的互动，一个非常有趣的互动，我非常高兴我们今天讨论了这个问题，并且我想说，如果你是一个相信“幸运女孩综合征”的人，恭喜你，这太棒了。人们有权拥有自己的观点，有权以某种特定的方式看待自己的生活。
If you've had a really amazing, wonderful, like inexplicable experience with Lucky Girl Syndrome, can you let me know? Because I really do want to hear about it. I find it really interesting watching these TikToks and being like, wow, how did she do because I'm even sold on it sometimes, having investigated this and looked at the science and the psychology. But like I said, we cannot discuss this idea or this trend without also acknowledging privilege, thinking about it on a deeper level. Maybe that was a controversial thing to say, but of course we cannot talk about something like Lucky Girl Syndrome or a trending sound on TikTok
如果你经历过非常惊人、美妙且无法解释的“幸运女孩综合征”，能告诉我吗？因为我真的很想听听。看着这些TikTok视频，我感到非常有趣，心想，哇，她是怎么做到的，因为有时甚至连我也被它说服了，尽管我已经调查过并研究了科学和心理学。但就像我说的，我们在讨论这个想法或趋势时，也不能不承认特权的存在，不去进行更深层次的思考。也许这样说会引发争议，但我们当然不能不谈论像“幸运女孩综合征”或TikTok上热门的音频这样的话题
or something like positive affirmations without also having a look into the deeper reasons behind why it's so compelling. And sometimes that does force us to acknowledge hard, controversial truths like privilege. I'm sorry if it offended you, but I do just think it's a valuable skill to think about things like Lucky Girl Syndrome, like anything in our lives, from different perspectives. So I really enjoyed this episode. It is probably one of my favorites. I really enjoyed looking into all the research and the science. I found so many unexpected things. Maybe you already knew all of this, in which case you are much smarter than me, and you should be running my podcast.
或者诸如积极自我肯定之类的事情，同时却不去探究它如此引人入胜的更深层原因。有时这确实迫使我们正视残酷、有争议的真相，比如特权。如果冒犯了你，我很抱歉，但我确实认为，从不同角度思考“幸运女孩综合征”或生活中的任何事物是一项很有价值的技能。所以我真的很喜欢这一期节目。它可能是我最喜欢的节目之一。我真的很享受查阅所有的研究和科学成果。我发现了许多意想不到的事情。也许你已经知道这一切了，那样的话你比我聪明得多，你应该来主持我的播客。
Please get in touch. But I really do hope that you learn something and that you're able to apply some of the things that we talked about today to your own life. That is always the aim of the show. And I am so glad if you've listened this far. As I always say, if you feel cool to do so, if you feel compelled, if you enjoyed this episode. Please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It really does help the show to reach new people. It's just me doing it here.
请与我联系。但我真的希望你能学到一些东西，并且能够将我们今天讨论的一些内容应用到你自己的生活中。这始终是节目的宗旨。如果你能听到这里，我真的非常高兴。正如我常说的，如果你觉得这样做很酷，如果你觉得有此意愿，如果你喜欢这一期节目。请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。这确实对节目触达新听众很有帮助。这里只有我一个人在做。
So it's really nice when people leave me really lovely reviews or they send me nice messages. It really does make my day. So if you want to join the community, if you have an episode that you think I should cover, I love to hear it. I love when people have ideas for me. So please follow us at that psychology podcast on Instagram. Follow along. See what you're up to. You're going to hear about what's coming next, things like merch, all of those wonderful things. So hopefully we will see you over there.
所以大家给我留下非常可爱的评论或者给我发来暖心的信息，我真的会觉得很开心。这确实让我一整天都有好心情。所以如果你想加入这个社群，如果你觉得有什么话题是我应该涵盖的，我很乐意听取。我喜欢大家为我提供创意。请在Instagram上关注我们@thatpsychology_podcast。关注我们的动态。看看你在忙些什么。你会听到关于接下来要推出的内容、周边产品以及所有这些美好事物的信息。希望我们在那边能见到你。
And we will be back on Tuesday for another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships,
我们周二会带着另一期节目回归。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇特现代世界中培养坚韧精神、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me.
你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听《回看过去》播客。对于1979年来说，对我而言那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着弄清楚我们是如何与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起从那个时期幸存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。在那之前，那是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of first.
嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学到的教训》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方进行都不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学到的教训》。在2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控首先
fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
怀上了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。